in this series i'm going to surprise you
i'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hard craft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
budding chef i want to give you the
confidence the recipes and the insider
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice round
wasting nothing
[Music]
i've been cooking in professional
kitchens for over 25 years what cheese
is in the macaroni now i've been taught
by some of the best chefs in the world
and in turn i've taught some of the best
how much whiskey's in there
now i'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes for fantastic
food that you can easily cook at home
incredible i'll be holding you by the
hand it's getting better and better and
better
teaching you everything from how to cook
with chili and spice to baking real fast
food and my ultimate feast recipes this
is the only cookery course you'll ever
need
[Music]
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
the fried pan is one of your best
friends it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and i'm going to show you how
first up my delicious pan fried pork
chops with sweet and sour peppers
whether it's in the restaurant or even
at home one of my golden rules for
producing fantastic food is learning to
cook with confidence this recipe is so
straightforward but tastes absolutely
amazing
pan on
get that nice and hot
you think of the sort of density of a
pork chop how it needs a little bit of
help
sweet sound peppers
go brilliantly well
first slice the peppers that's the flat
side of the pepper so stand it up trying
to slice a pepper
on the side is a nightmare there's the
center
start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around
and down
and look i see one
now place the pepper down
three finger rule one finger in front
two behind
pinky holding it down thumb holding it
nice and flat the flatter the vegetables
the more confident you are when you
slice so
don't worry about the speed
just let the knife do the work
and take your time
speed comes
the most important thing
is to get your technique right
red onion
now sweet sour peppers
olive oil in
i'm going to saute them which is just
the chef's turn for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum taste
some salt and pepper
add a tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to
break down the peppers quicker but
caramelize the onions frying them in a
frying pan perfect it's one of the sort
of basic essential tools of any kitchen
because it's so multi-purpose
great for sauteing
tossing
great for cooking fish on meat
push away and pull back push away and
pull back that hissing is something you
need to hear constantly because
the minute that's gone your peppers and
your onions start to boil and you really
want them to soak in
you now start to see it's glistening in
a way that it's starting to caramelize
sugar's working beautifully
that's ready pour the red wine vinegar
in
smells incredible it helps to stain the
peppers as well look at the glaze now
you can see the sugar
it's worked as magic
turn down the gas and add a couple of
tablespoons of fresh
extra virgin olive oil
let them stew for two to three minutes
now i want to make the peppers nice and
light and sort of sweet aromatic
just roll the basil
almost like a big cigar
slice
basil in
and then literally cook it out for 30
seconds i want them off
beautiful
okay pan back on
now for the pork chops
i want to make sure
they don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly
a few simple cuts through the rind means
the chop stays flat and cooks evenly
point the knife down
flip through it's seasoned them
beautifully
nice large
shards of pepper punch that through
lightly guaranteed that seasoning
is going to stay there
hot pan touch garlic and touch of thyme
the garlic
take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on
crush it
olive oil in
just starting to smoke
top of the chop
in
and lay away from me
nice
keep that heat in the pan
put the garlic in there early
a nice fragrant bunch of thyme
see how the pork is staying nice and
flat
turn that over
i want a little bit of thyme underneath
there
start squeezing that garlic out i want
the flavor coming out
butter in
thin slices of butter
tilt the pan and baste so i'm sort of
speeding up the cooking process at the
same time i'm keeping the pork chop
really nice and moist
and now look at the color that butter
it's almost like sort of a nut brown
check the color on the other side useful
when they're that thick
three and a half to four minutes each
side 30 seconds from now they're gonna
be medium so i'm gonna take them out and
let them rest
the secret to perfectly moist pork chops
is letting them rest almost as long as
they're cooked in the pan
[Music]
a nice spoon
of these peppers the basil smells
incredible
keep that garlic on there be generous
with that vinaigrette from the peppers
because it really is incredible
do two things simple like that pork and
peppers
and your confidence is gonna shoot
through the roof a stunning pork chop
with sweet and sour peppers
the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different dishes
the more you cook with your frying pan
the more your confidence will grow
here are three of my favorite easy
pan-fried dishes
first up pan fried scallops with crunchy
apple salad
[Music]
get a frying pan smoking hot essential
for quick pan frying
add olive oil
then season scallops with salt and
pepper
starting at the top put clockwise into
the pan so you know which one to turn
first
[Music]
scallops have firm white sweet flesh and
cook in minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
next salad lamb's lettuce
matchsticks of apple
seasoning
lemon zest and juice
[Applause]
[Music]
add olive oil then toss
[Music]
turn the scallops when golden go
clockwise around the pan
[Applause]
then squeeze in lemon juice and give the
pan a shake
finish with lemon zest
ready in under 10 minutes my first pan
fried dish scallops with crunchy apple
salad
my next super simple pan fried recipe is
chicken and chicory in masala sauce
[Music]
season the chicken breasts
add to hot olive oil skin side down lay
away from you to stop the all splashing
[Music]
sliced chicory this versatile vegetable
can be red all white has a lovely bitter
taste and is great cooked all raw
crush a clove of garlic and add
then sprigs of thyme
[Music]
when the chicken skin is crisp turn over
along with the chicory
for the sauce add masala a sweet
fortified wine from sicily
then 150ml of chicken stock
to make the sauce wonderfully rich and
glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes
[Music]
plate up and spoon over the sauce
cooked in under 20 minutes chicken and
chicory in masala sauce
[Music]
my final dish cooked in the versatile
frying pan is
sea bream with tomato and herb salsa
[Music]
fry fillets of sea bream skin side down
in hot olive oil
if they buckle up press gently down for
perfect even cooking then season
sea bream has firm white flesh perfect
for pan frying
next the salsa
heat olive oil
add half cherry tomatoes
pitted black olives
and season
[Music]
after a minute on a low heat add
coriander basil and lemon
[Music]
combine and leave to infuse
[Music]
as the sea bream cooks it goes opaque
when it's two-thirds from the top turn
over
[Music]
baste fry and it's done
[Music]
sebring with tomato and herb salsa ready
in under 15 minutes
one pan three simple impressive and
absolutely delicious dishes beautiful
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
along with a hundred recipes to stake
your life on i'm gonna give you a
hundred quick cooking tips to make your
life in the kitchen easier
first up how to keep your knife sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife
sharpen it before and every time you use
it first grip the steel feel really
comfortable about holding the still
imagine you're holding a tennis racquet
or you're playing squash you've got to
be really comfortable with it now 45
degrees confident grip confident grip
with a knife this is the butt of the
steel really important to keep your
fingers behind there you never grip a
steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over steel
stroke
and we start from the bottom to the top
so there
across
there
across
slow strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back underneath
then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is ten times quicker more
efficient now
that's ready to start chopping
to stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
[Music]
now you can chop with confidence
[Music]
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra thin
ribbons of veg perfect for asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads
it also makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think
tighten the top screw to get finely
ground pepper ideal for soups and sauces
[Music]
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head crush separate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
[Music]
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
i'll be showing you a roast chicken
recipe to die for hold the drum and
slice straight through
but first like any good chef i'm always
looking to get great ingredients at the
right price
my shopping mantra is simple
first rely on your senses make sure
whatever you're buying it looks smells
and really feels good and if you get the
chance taste it before you buy it second
is to recognize that knowledge is
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients come from and how they
produce the better so ask lots of
questions and learn
you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds one person knows what to
look for is award-winning fifth
generation master butcher danny lid gain
poultry is a great meat because there's
many different types of birds it's worth
tasting the variation of flavours
between different first to birds is
massive
turkey's a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty meats it's a really healthy
flavoursome meal
game birds people don't try them often
enough once they're shot they're hung up
for a little while but a few days at
least it means the meat's going to be
more tender it all adds flavor to the
birds
we've got a wood pigeon and a red leg
partridge both really good and cook
really quickly
when you're buying a chicken some of the
things to look out for is obviously the
smell
and when you're smelling a good quality
chicken you can tell the difference the
skin's a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chickeny smell
when you're buying from a good butcher
you'll find you tend to get the giblets
as well which is basically the neck and
other organs this is great for making
gravy
once you have cooked it you can use all
the offcuts for other things stir-fries
curries pasta dishes save the bones use
the bones for stocks and soups a really
packed full of flavor
and remember there are lots of different
breeds of chicken all have different
characteristics and flavors so shop
around and find the ones you love here
are three of my all-time favorites
the label anglais
these come from an old british breed
they've got smaller breasts but the
meat's delicious
the black leg a fantastic french variety
succulent with bags of flavour and
really meaty thighs
and the pulley divorce
this is the rolls royce of chickens rich
gamey and delicious one for special
occasions
i think people should maybe try and buy
less meat but aim for the best quality
you're only going to get out what you
put in by putting the best quality into
a dish you're going to get the best
results
no matter how seasoned the chef you are
there are always new ingredients and
recipes to get fired up about
so if a tired old recipe is getting you
down spice it up with fresh ideas and
flavors my next recipe is an old classic
roast chicken but with a simple twist it
takes on a new life and it's guaranteed
to impress
one of the things i love about cooking
and it keeps me excited after 25 years
behind the stove is that there's always
something new to learn every day new
ingredients new techniques and new
cuisines
start off with the stuffing
[Music]
it's amazing how exciting i stuffed
roast chicken can be because it keeps
the chicken incredibly moist and gives a
delicious texture inside the bird
i'm going to start off with cured ceriso
this is a traditional spanish sausage
and it's
garlicky
spicy
incredibly meaty
that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing
get that cerezo in
start cooking that down and getting all
those oils out
touch of olive oil in there to get it
going right onions
chopped
add the onions to the cerezo and in a
matter of seconds they'll change color
as they soak up all the flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic
garlicky
fresh thyme just hold it down and put
your fingers on there and it's a really
nice way of taking off all those nice
fragrant little time flowers
you can hear it crackling in the
background
these are cannellini beans
they're waxy
very soft
and so delicious but very dense but for
stuffing they're so robust nothing
breaks down
drain them off
in
they're going to take on all that juice
as well from this freezer i'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some help
i mean that looks like it's
a dish on its own good enough to eat now
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
tomatoes half dried
in
that sweetens up
the stuffing
beautiful
the stuffing's ready look at the color
everything
looks spanish it looks delicious
now
stuffing the chicken i like taking off
these little knuckles
as the chicken cooks the skin stretches
over the bone you can get a really nice
drum and take off those little wingtips
as well
salt pepper
so important
now
you're stuffing
i'm gonna go right inside the chicken
push it down this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces in the carcass
and take a nice large lemon
push the lemon in
pick up the person's nose
pull the skin
over olive oil on top
salt
and pepper
a teaspoon of paprika
sprinkle it on and then get your hands
and sort of rub that in
and see what the paprika is doing to the
chicken putting this like sweet spicy
marinade
it's not even roasted yet but it looks
delicious
[Music]
400 ml of white wine same quantity of
water that helps the chicken to steam
chicken in be generous with the time
sprigs
[Music]
make sure the fall is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy
into the oven
[Music]
cook for one hour at 180 degrees with a
foil on nice
take it out and remove the full lid then
give it another 30 minutes to crisp up
that skin
look at that
it's so important to make sure you take
that tinfoil off with half an hour to go
beautiful
pierce that open
squeeze it in that delicious gravy mix
that into the tray
and sieve that
that's really nice fragrant lemony
spiced roasting juices to finish
before we cut up the chicken take out
amazing stuffing
[Music]
incredible i'd have that with chicken
over potatoes any day
and then just get your chicken roasting
juices
now
to cut the chicken up
hold the drum
and slice straight through
and there's a wonderful drum and the
thigh through the wishbone
off
slice with the point at an angle so you
can see the texture
of that amazing roast chicken
just take my cooking juices just want to
give a really nice sort of lemony flavor
over my chicken and there you go
a delicious
very charming stuffed
roast chicken
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stake your life on
right put your feet up for my perfect tv
dinners
[Music]
like all chefs good food is my life and
for me tv dinners are all about recipes
that are fuss-free quick and easy to
make so however busy you are you can
always knock up brilliant food
my tv dinners need minimum shopping and
rely on the staple ingredients you
already have in the cupboard so you can
enjoy incredible dishes
whenever you want
starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters
so you've got all that opening up and
then just rinse the top of that to get
rid of any potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
gonna add a touch of chicken stock in
there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken stock would reduce down by half
and it's almost delays at the bottom of
the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the ball and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just gonna turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve
on a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat
with foolproof pasta recipes up your
sleeve you'll always be able to knock up
a fantastic lunch or supper
here are three more of my super fast
pasta dishes that are bursting with
flavour and cooking minutes
kicking off with farfalli with ricotta
pancetta and peas
[Music]
start by frying lardons in a large pan
these smoked chunks of bacon have a
delicious deep salty flavour that makes
them perfect with pasta when the
lavender start to brown add finely
chopped garlic and turn off the heat
next add farfeli to boiling salted water
[Music]
named after the italian for butterflies
this bow tied shaped pasta has a large
surface area great for sticking to
sauces
just before the pasta is ready add
frozen peas to the boiling past the
water
then when the pasta and the peas are
cooked drain and add to the lardons and
the garlic
spoon in creme fraiche
[Music]
and dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese
[Music]
season
then serve
ready in just 12 minutes
farfeli with ricotta pancetta and peas
a delicious quick and easy supper that's
ready when you are
my next pronto pasta dish
is taglitelli with quick sausage meat
bolognese
[Music]
first bowl dry taglitelli and salted
water these long thin ribbons of pasta
come curled up in less and take around
10 minutes to cook
then add olive oil to a hot pan
and fry finely chopped onion
thinly slice garlic
and sweat until soft
[Music]
next remove the meat from your sausages
by cutting open their skins and crumble
into the pan
fennel or sicilian sausages are perfect
for this dish but any flavour sausage
will do
when the meat has browned add half
cherry tomatoes
season
[Music]
and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta
cooking water as the starch thickens the
sauce and helps it stick to the pasta
drain the teglatelli and add to the
sausage meat sauce
[Music]
finish with freshly grated parmesan
[Music]
perfect when you're really busy but
still want great tasting food fast my
amazing taglitelli with quick sausage
meat bolognese
[Applause]
my final pasta dish that's ready in a
flash and packs a real flavor punch
a spaghetti with chili sardines and
oregano
[Music]
first for the crunchy topping heat olive
oil in a frying pan
add chopped garlic
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook over medium heat until the
breadcrumbs are golden
season
and drain on kitchen paper
for the sauce add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan
fry finely diced chili
and chopped garlic
next cook dry spaghetti in boiling water
then chop tin sardines into chunks
and add to the chili and garlic
tin sardines are a brilliantly versatile
ingredient to have in your cupboard
packed with protein full of super
healthy omega-3 oils and delicious
next drain your pasta and combine with
the sardine chili and garlic mixture
add leaves of fresh oregano
and mix in handfuls of rocket
to serve
pile high and top with the crispy garlic
breadcrumbs
[Music]
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy
hearty and full of flavor perfect pasta
in moments
[Applause]
whether you're rushing to put your feet
up in front of the telly and need
something fast and tasty for the family
or simply want something delicious to
enjoy these are three amazing pasta
recipes you can learn by heart and cook
in minutes
beautiful
[Music]
now here are five more of my essential
cooking tips starting with how to cook
an ingredient that's perfect for a quick
and easy tv dinner chicken breasts
this has to be the most popular part of
the chicken now it's very versatile
incredibly tender very lean hardly any
fat whatsoever the secret is cooking it
without it becoming dry
the first thing is to season it properly
both sides
two tablespoons of olive oil
get the pan nice and hot
the secret now
is to get a really nice color on the
skin
really nice color
no color no flavor skin side down
tilt the pan so it cooks the back of the
chicken breast where it's really nice
and round and very fat
let the pan do the work
chicken breast normally takes between
sort of 10 and 12 minutes to cook
properly
now we've got the color on the skin the
skin's nice and crispy we're going to
deglaze the pan
deglaze with masala now masala has a
sweet fortified italian wine you can
also use white wine
masala in
flambe
burn off the alcohol which gets rid of
that really sort of harsh alcoholic
flavor
roll the chicken around the masala
the glaze in the pan basically means
washing the pan
and lifting off all that flavor stuck to
the bottom of the frying pan and put it
into the sauce
now chicken stock
bring that up to the boil and let it
simmer for three to four minutes
[Music]
really important to leave the chicken
breast skin side up the skin's nice and
crispy and it's important that the
chicken cooks from underneath as it
starts cooking it absorbs the stock so
in the center of the chicken stays nice
and moist
[Music]
now the stock of the masala is reduced
down it's gonna have the confidence to
allow it to almost disappear
and look
the combination between the masala and
the chicken stock is quite sweet so it
finishes the chicken with this really
nice delicious glaze on top
and there you go a delicious succulent
chicken breast with the most amazing
flavoursome skin phenomenal
soups make stunningly simple meals my
tip for adding incredible depth of
flavor is to always keep your leftover
parmesan rinds store them in the freezer
then add to the pan as the soup cooks
and leaves to infuse then remove before
serving it's less waste and more taste
another tip to take homemade soup to the
next level whisking cubes of cold butter
just before serving to get a glossy
velvety texture and a beautifully rich
taste
another fantastic standard for a
frost-free weekend eat is the classic
baked potato
my tip for great crispy skin is to use
salt to your advantage simply add it to
the outside before cooking and the salt
will draw out the moisture in the oven
as it bakes
a touch of salt gives you an amazingly
crisp skin on chicken and fish too as
well as highlighting the flavor
[Music]
home roasted nuts make a delicious tv
snack my tip for peeling them with these
is to simply toast them in the oven for
about 10 minutes wrap in a tea towel and
rub until the skins are removed
perfect sprinkle with sea salt and so
with a glass of wine
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on
coming up i'll be showing you my amazing
sweet corn fritters
that is such a delicious recipe but
first the key to whipping up my ultimate
tv dinners is having a well-stocked
store covered and even with the basics
like tin sardines tomatoes pasta or rice
it always pays to know how to buy the
best
next up my shopping guide to all things
pasta
when it comes to the sacred italian
staple you'll be hard-pressed to find
anyone who knows more than pastor
supremo antonio
i love pasta so much i have to eat it at
least once a day
he's been selling perfect pasta in
london soho for over 35 years and eating
great pasta for a lifetime
to make the best place in the world
italy
takes away the past in italy and the
people died you know and that's it
for a good very good pasta you need two
ingredients you need a good egg and very
good flour and that's it this is a durum
wheat flour look at that it's so soft
does it cook so quick a couple minutes
in a boiling water this thin like this
couple minutes it's cool
this shop is not it's not big enough to
store all the type of pasta this is the
famous
spaghetto albronzo this is penne
antonio's right there's a mind-blowing
array of incredible pasta types that are
great to keep in your store cupboard
here's my quick guide to some of the
different shapes and sizes and how to
use them
small shapes like farfallini are perfect
for making simple stews and soups more
substantial and add an extra texture to
dishes like the classic italian pasta
soup
minestrone tubes like penne are great
for thick cream or tomato based sauces
as the rigid edges hold more sauce for
an incredibly flavored packed mouthful
long and thin like the store cupboard
essential spaghetti the classic shape
was invented in naples but every italian
region has its own spaghetti dish from
bolognese to carbonara or my favorite a
lavongale which is spaghetti with
delicious steamed clams
flat noodles shaped strands like
fettuccine are perfect with a simple
drizzle of olive oil or in rich buttery
dishes as a little sauce goes a long way
coating the pasta evenly stopping the
strands from sticking together
then pass the sheets not just great for
lasagnas but amazing rolled into tubes
and filled to make delicious calalonie
or used in quick supper dishes like my
mushroom and leek pasta
finally speciality pastas like this
spaghetti made with squid ink has
delicately sweet taste and an amazing
jet black color
great for when you want a delicious
dinner that's a little bit different
whatever shape you go for always look
out for the pastas that have been bronze
cut it means the dough was pressed
through a bronze cutting dye which has a
subtle rough texture which helps the
sauce stick as well as all the dried
types pasta also comes fresh which is
brilliant for tv dinners because it
cooks super quick and tastes incredible
too
in this shop we make pasta every day
look at that that's beautiful
it's sad to eat it this pasta is really
really yellow because we use good
quality of eggs you can
smell the eggs they come through
it's so good so fresh you can even
eat it raw like that
it lasts in the fridge two or three days
you can even freeze it and you want
chain taste whether fresh or dried pasta
so versatile and quick to cook is the
perfect tv dinner so go out stock up on
new shaves and you'll soon be turning
out dishes that would make pasta pro
antonio very proud it looks so nice so
good so healthy
you know and that's it can resist
we all lead busy lives but that doesn't
mean you have to compromise when it
comes to cooking great food
for me the secret is having recipes you
can depend on and a stalker full of
staple ingredients that can be
transformed into quick delicious dinners
on demand
so shop smart stock up and whether
you're feeding 2 or 20 you'll always be
ready to cook up something incredible
my next tasty dish uses simple and cheap
store cupboard ingredients with stunning
results
and takes minutes to make
sweet corn fritters and yogurt dip
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
and just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg
about four tablespoons of milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chili so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
of slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch
in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients
and one third of the mixture to bind
together that's the secret of good
freighter so you're
you're biting into excitement and not
sort of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
i'm happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
de-seed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
[Music]
and then
some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that a nice mix up
that chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
it tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking